[Música]
a las 7 de la mañana
suena el despertador la hora que menos
esperas te llegó la hora de levantarse
ese quejido que tienes demuestra lo
mucho que no quieres
salir de tu cama que estás calentito
entonces decides agarrar tu celular
donde está tu alarma y darle cinco
minutitos más
vuelve a sonar el despertador
decides por fin darle el punto final
para apagar esa alarma después de cinco
postergaciones
abres un ojo agarras tu celular y dices
bueno voy a revisar mis redes sociales
sale la chica que me gusta me escribió
quien sabe me perdí alguna fiesta veo
vídeos nuevos de youtube y como me doy
cuenta ya está totalmente repetitivo
ese momento dices bueno ya me está
llegando el sol en la cara debo
levantarme el programa tantas cosas por
hoy ves la hora y dices no me alcanza
lo hago mañana ya no importa lo hago
mañana
esta historia se va repitiendo muchas
veces y lo he visto en mí y en amigos
muy cercanos
muchas veces postergamos las tareas que
nosotros nos hemos programado un día
antes y nos hace difícil lograr
conseguir los sueños que alguna vez
hemos planificado llega el momento en el
que despiertas y miras a tu alrededor y
te ves envuelto en una vida rutinaria
donde haces lo mismo cada día esperas el
final de tu jornada laboral los viernes
es lo porque más ansias y odias los
lunes
incluso hostias memes de que odias los
y en el momento donde un chispazo de
motivación te muestra
que puede ser más de lo que eres en ese
momento
te miras al espejo y dices
dónde está esa persona que yo había
dicho que iba a ser ese niño joven
emprendedor que estaba detrás tuyo
comienza a salir y te dice si hemos
prometido viajar por todo el mundo con
vernos al mundo conocer muchas personas
ayudarlas e incluso dejar huella
dónde está todo eso
comienzas a sentir algo que no sabes de
dónde llegó pero eso lo va a determinar
cuando tú estabas durmiendo tenías una
voz en tu cabeza que te decían
duerme puedes descansar que es una
horita más tranquilo estás calientitos
contando una horita para que vuelvas a
dormir y este es mucho más tranquilo
esa voz en tu cabeza puede llegar a ser
una gran enemiga y es como vamos a
encontrar cuál es el camino para lograr
cambiar esto
una vez que esa persona ha tomado la
decisión de que va a hacer algo mejor
dice ok qué es lo que voy a hacer bueno
tengo muchas ideas oye si a mí se me
ocurrió alguna vez que yo podía hacer
eso porque no están haciendo eso si es
igual que lo así es millonario
agarras todos los prototipos que alguna
vez pensaste armas el primero tienes ya
tu prototipo y vas donde las personas
más cercanas tus amigos tus familiares
las preguntas que te parece patrones y
si muy bonito muy lindo cambia el estilo
vuelves lo terminas haces las
modificaciones y sales al mundo todo
feliz con esa idea que va a revolucionar
el mundo bueno por lo menos eso pasa en
tu cabeza
ese momento él decide emprender
es el cambio que tiene en su vida y no
sabe cómo hacerlo pero sabe que lo hará
y recibe el primer golpe en la cara no
sabe ni siquiera vender el mundo no está
preparado tal vez para él o él no está
preparado para el mundo y recibe su no
gracias joven vuelve mañana
así va repitiendo su historia toda la
semana llega al final la jornada se
hecha en su cama y tiene dos decisiones
para tomar
o lo deja todo vuelve a su zona de
confort está tranquilito en su trabajo
donde estaba donde no tenía nada de
problemas
o se levanta y consigue los sueños y
todo aquello que alguna vez lo motivó
agarra de nuevo de sus bolsillos y hay
más polvo lunar que dinero
tengo biogás nuevo que voy a hacer
porque tengo mi prototipo acá mi pareja
me va a dejar no me importa con aire me
querrá
y así es como comienza una persona a
salir de esa zona de confort porque
existe una meta más grande un sueño al
cual va a poder lograr alcanzar qué
tiene de diferente aquellas personas que
lograron o ese amigo que tú tenías que
ni siquiera tenía muy buenas notas pero
ahora maneja una empresa y es reconocido
por muchos lugares o ese deportista que
representa un país y que logra ganar
todo lo que se propone y además tiene
muy buen físico que tiene de diferente
escribieron ese extra que nadie más se
atreve a dar porque decidieron salirse
de esa voz que te agarra y te dice mira
qué tal si estás en tu camisa o si es
que llegas a fracasar te dice vuelve
donde estabas estábamos bien tal vez
puedes ganar más experiencia y recién te
animas necesitas aprender un poco más
de miras al espejo
y le hablas esa voz en tu cabeza que es
tu cerebro que tiene la misión número
uno de sobrevivir y para sobrevivir tu
cerebro va a ahorrar la mayor cantidad
de energía que pueda esa es su misión y
lo hace muy bien por eso es que nos
cuesta tanto tomar algo que requiera
mucho esfuerzo
pero tienes que agarrar mirarlo y
decirle sabes que no me importa que me
digas que no soy capaz de hacer lo que
no estoy preparado para lograr lo que
necesito muchos más años de experiencia
o que necesito muchas cosas más para
hacerlo
he decidido alcanzar mis sueños y el que
manda soy yo
dejemos un poco del lado de esta
historia
voy a contarles cómo ha sido un poco de
la mía yo me he sentido muy representado
con esta historia y he visto muchos
amigos pasar por todo este camino
a un inicio cuando yo estaba en la
universidad a los finales años tenía
ideas tenía prototipos yo quería cambiar
y revolucionar y hacer casas
inteligentes que cuando llegue me digan
hola wilmar quieres un vinito así lo
contaba algún día lo haré
pero las cosas van cambiando y mientras
estaba estudiando
quise sacar una empresa que pueda
revolucionar con tecnología pero yo no
sabía cómo venderlo no sabía qué precio
darle entonces un momento tenía un amigo
que estaba estudiando una carrera de
marketing y le pregunté cómo puedo hacer
para sacar un producto y qué precio
ponerle me dices bueno
puedes salir a hacer encuestas grupos
focales entrevistas y yo digo que si yo
odio hacer encuestas no me gusta que me
pregunte yo no tengo idea por ejemplo si
me van a decir cuánta leche usted
consume al mes o al año no tengo idea
son preguntas que uno la responde ese
momento y no es sincero responder a lo
que su realidad o lo que piense o
incluso si el entrevistador es vomita
tal vez digas mentiras
saldrá
no me convencía y es así que mientras yo
iba desarrollando la primera empresa
es aquí
la segunda que está tratada que trata
del neuromarketing neuromarketing es no
es una ciencia pero sí es una
herramienta que utiliza ciertos aspectos
como la psicología del consumidor donde
entiendes el por qué suceden las cosas
me gustó mucho el comportamiento y me di
cuenta de que nosotros no habían sido
tan racionales como pensábamos sino que
somos más emocionales y para conseguir
nuestra meta
teníamos que primero satisfacer lo que
teníamos dentro y que nos mueva es por
eso que hemos desarrollado con mi equipo
una matriz que es para la toma de
decisiones de compra que fue tan
interesante que la adapte para los
emprendedores y poder ayudar a las
personas a encontrar su vocación y su
pasión cómo funciona esta matriz
esta matriz consta de cinco pasos
el primer paso de la matriz es la
atención cuando tú quieras desarrollar
algo tienes que llamar tu atención y
para esto nosotros vamos a comenzar con
esta técnica que es hackear nuestra
mente como jaque amos nuestra mente
hackear es lograr un objetivo buscando
nuevos caminos y para lograrlo debemos
cómo reprogramar nuestra cabeza para que
él entienda que la misión que vamos a
hacer sea más importante de cualquier
otra cosa que sea el motor de lo que tú
vas a hacer te tiene que llamar la
atención es muy obvio pero no todo el
mundo lo entiende
es difícil comprenderlo y tienes que
hacer verte en retrospectiva y comenzar
a buscar cuál será tu motor algo que
realmente digas yo quiero saber de esto
me despierto y quiero hacer esto y
quiero que me hablen solamente de esto
el primer punto es la atención
el segundo
es la emoción
tu sueño tu idea debe ser tan fuerte que
te genere todas las emociones emoción
viene de la palabra movimiento debe
moverte y cuando tú agarras todas las
emociones que existen como la alegría la
tristeza la ira el miedo y las pones a
tu favor con ese proyecto ese sueño
tiene que ser algo que realmente te
alegre por tenerlo te ponga triste
cuando tú no estés te pongas sorpresa
cuando descubras algo nuevo te de ira
cuando alguien hable mal de eso y
descubras todas esas emociones estarás
más cerca de lograr algo que realmente
te mueva para hacer las cosas
el tercer paso
es el compromiso de nada me sirva algo
que me llame la atención que realmente
me genere todas las emociones si yo no
tengo un compromiso o una meta a donde
quiero llegar
voy a sacar mi remos voy a mover no sé
dónde voy a llegar pero sí sé a qué
puerto estoy apuntando es más probable
que llegues y tus sueños tienen que ser
ambiciosos tiene que doler tiene que
darte miedo y tienes que utilizar ese
miedo volviendo a cambiar la perspectiva
que en vez de que digas no tengo miedo
puede fracasar me puede ir mal a decir
no tengo miedo de seguir en este lugar y
este miedo me va a impulsar a que yo lo
consiga
el compromiso es una meta tan grande que
tienes que apuntar super alto para
llegar lo apunta alto no tengas miedo
porque los sueños se logran conseguir en
lo más que una de las personas más
revolucionarias en tecnología que
existen y está muy cerca de querer nos
llevará a marte
hemos logrado llegar a la luna han sido
sueños que para generaciones anteriores
eran solamente algo que ni se imaginaban
consigue esa meta ese sueño que te llame
la atención te genera las emociones y
encuentra el camino
el cuarto lugar es el hábito de qué me
sirve tener la meta tener la motivación
algo que me guste si al final yo no
puedo motivarme todas las mañanas cuando
ustedes se levantan todos los días hoy
lo voy a romper es difícil para eso no
podemos ser siempre motivados
necesitamos ser disciplinados
y esto genera hábitos que ustedes lo
vayan repitiendo cada vez si quiero
tener una sonrisa linda tendré que
lavarme tres veces al día la boca y así
voy a poder tener unos dientes blancos y
para hacerlo voy a tener que todas las
noches con todo mi enojo al lavarme la
boca despierto y me halagó la boca y así
durante un tiempo hasta que ya sea parte
de mí
si ya te llamó la atención te genera las
emociones tienes ese compromiso la meta
y has logrado generar hábitos
lo más difícil es continuar los y para
esto podemos utilizar a nuestro cerebro
otra vez a nuestro favor utilizando los
neurotransmisores los neurotransmisores
como por ejemplo la endorfina nos genera
felicidad todo aquello que nos recuerde
a momentos felices si de pronto te
sientes desmotivado escucha las
canciones que más te gustaban en tu
juventud que te hacían bailar recuerda
momentos felices sal con un amigo de la
infancia
la serotonina es la ausencia de la
serotonina te genera tristeza y debes
contrarrestarlo con lo que es la
endorfina y lo siguiente es la dopamina
es una de las hormonas que te generan
placer y lo que nos da placer hace que
volvamos a querer repetirlo por eso la
adrenalina los momentos felices siempre
los queremos hacer y cómo podemos
generar este neurotransmisor que es tan
importante
agarras y tú me estás súper lejana
entonces pones micro pasos que irás
consiguiendo que te serán fácil y tú
podrás sentirte feliz cada vez que
logres esos pequeños micro pasos que
irás anotando es diferente decirlo que
anotar tu meta esos micro pasos y te
además te comes un chocolatito eso te va
a generar el placer para que tú
reprograme sat y mismo y puedas
continuar
y el último es la oxitocina no te
olvides de las personas que te quieren
un abrazo genera la oxitocina y es tan
importante que incluso hace que las
madres se olviden del dolor que tienen
al momento del parto para realmente
bañarse de oxitocina y demostrar el amor
que tienen a su hijo lo mismo es con los
sueños y las metas que tengas abrazar
quiere no te olvides de la parte humana
una vez que ya ha generado mi hábito el
logrado reprogramar el cerebro que yo
tenía es muy difícil conseguir a veces
el conocimiento o estos hábitos ya lo
que me enseñó mi papá y que fue
fundamental para mí mientras él vivía
fue aprender a aprender
y aprender a aprender
no es sencillo porque debes tener tú la
conciencia de ti mismo para adquirir
nuevos conocimientos hace 20 años el
internet era algo que nadie se iba
imaginar que iba a tener en la palma de
su mano toda la información y ahora que
la tenemos tampoco es que somos una gran
cosa verdad
entonces aprender a aprender es una
herramienta fundamental que cambiará su
mundo y el último paso que es el más
importante de todos la acción
si ustedes no toman la acción de nada
sirve todo lo que han planificado usado
estudiado
motivado perseguido porque no han tomado
la acción la diferencia entre los que
hacen y no hacen es de los que hacen
tomar una acción lo hicieron y el tiempo
pasa uno piensa cuando es joven de que
tiene el tiempo del mundo y no se da
cuenta de que ese recurso más importante
que tenemos porque es lo único que no
podemos evitar el paso del tiempo
si nosotros no tomamos acción ahora y
esperamos a que la vida te dé un golpe
de nada nos servirá no esperes que la
vida te dé ese golpe escucha ese niño
que te dice vamos lograrlo sueña alcanza
si quiere ser astronauta hazlo si
quieres conquistar aquella chica que te
gusta
hazlo si quieres conseguir un sueño loco
hazlo
solo
escucha tu niño toma acción enamórate de
tu sueño de tu meta y llegarás muy lejos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]